well you spend the money man you went to
Ohio where he was born and raised and
what happened you bought how many
tickets to the Cincinnati Reds game ran
you about a thousand bucks you say hi
everybody I'm in the Diamond Club
where's the diamond Club I pay for my
buffet what did you eat at the buffet
I'll take one thing of that let me show
you how to order because I'm pretty
sophisticated now I'll take one thing to
prepare DS a thing of fish and a thing
of the prime wear but just one thing
what else did he do while he was home
besides been thousands of dollars to see
a baseball game yeah and a diamond did
you stay with your family hotel maybe
have them all pile in on him when they
come oh yeah he's sleeping on an air
match dad our marital bed of yours I
told my wife if there aren't mint on the
pillow I ain't sleeping there what did
that whole weekend cost you dude yeah I
had plane tickets hotel food did you
treat the family to dinner every night
part your car don't worry or mourning
all gourd hurt I mean this [ __ ] kid
he wants to show up in Cincinnati like
he's rockefeller let me handle all the
dinners here yeah yeah for everyone
everyone at the preferred where can we
go next big vacation why I got my
honeymoon later this year were you going
doing that Napa and Napa
what's that kind of cost oh that's
expensive why do you need to go to Napa
go build a nest egg listen to me I'm
warning you with peace and love Courtney
in New Hampshire hi I was listening to
the whole JD talking about is a
honeymoon Napa is one of the most
expensive places to go I just got back
from there for six days it was probably
around five six thousand you hear this
$6000 what the [ __ ] I'm spending my
money on leave me alone what happened
between hey JD what happened between the
time like I was just talking to you and
you were normal now you just did you get
angry after I stopped you turned it to
the Incredible Hulk man I'm telling you
where's Bruce Banner we gotta talk yeah
why did you see JD come off like that
you never ever yelled at me like that
before JD oh no no no it's okay I kind
of like it turning me on I just wish I
knew those secret worries
JD Popat are you upset